so what we have are three different
pictures of substances
undergoing some type of change and what
we're going to focus on in this video
is classifying things as either being
physical changes
or chemical changes and you might have
already thought about this or seen this
in a previous
science class but when we talk about a
physical change
we're talking about where there could be
a change in properties but we're not
having a change in the actual
composition of what we're talking about
while in a chemical change you actually
do have a change in composition
how the different constituent atoms and
elements match up or connect or bond to
each other
might be different so my first question
to you is
pause this video and we have some ice
melting here we have some propane
combusting or burning here and we have
some
iron rusting here and i want to think
about which of these are physical
changes and which of these are chemical
changes and why
all right now let's first think about
this water this ice
melting and if we wanted to write it in
fancy
chemical language or chemistry language
we could write this as
h2o going from its solid form
to h2o going into its liquid form
now we don't have a change in
composition in either state whether
you're looking at this liquid water here
whether you're looking at the solid
water there you'll see a bunch of
water molecules each oxygen
is still bonded to two hydrogens
and so you're not having a change in
composition
and so this over here is a physical
physical change and if we kept heating
that water up and it started to vaporize
that would also be a physical change
whereas
it turns into water vapor you have your
intermolecular forces being overcome
but the covalent bonds between the
oxygens and the hydrogens
those aren't breaking or forming in some
way
so once again when you go from ice to
water physical change from water to
vapor
or you could say from liquid to gas that
is also going to be
a physical change one general rule of
thumb when you think about what's going
on on a microscopic level and this is a
general rule of thumb it doesn't always
apply and we'll think about an edge case
in a little bit
is when you're overcoming intermolecular
forces
that tends to be a physical change but
if you have chemical bonds
forming or breaking that would be a
chemical change now let's think about
what's going on here with the propane
if you were to write the chemical
reaction here it would be
propane c3h8 in gas form
it needs oxygen to combust so for every
mole of propane we have five moles of
molecular oxygen
in gas form and then
when it combusts you're going to produce
three
for every one mole of propane and five
moles of molecular oxygen you're going
to produce three moles of carbon
dioxide gas and
four moles of water in
vapor form as well and so what you
actually have is
the bonds in those molecules are
actually breaking and then re-forming
so you don't just have physical change
going on here
you have chemical change chemical
change one way to think about it you had
protein propane
here before c3h8 after the reaction you
no longer
have the propane here what you actually
see as fire which is
fascinating this is just very hot gas
and that very hot air that you're seeing
and there's going to be some carbon
dioxide in there and there's going to be
some
water vapor in there the reason why it's
getting so hot
is because this releases a lot of energy
now let's think about what's going on
here with this iron
if i were to write this as a chemical
reaction
for every four moles of iron in solid
form
plus three moles of molecular oxygen
in gas form and that would just be the
ambient oxygen around this iron
it is going to produce two moles of
iron oxide as
a solid and that's what you see there
in the orange that is the iron oxide so
notice this reaction is forming
new ionic bonds in that ferrous oxide
and to undergo the reaction we have to
break the metallic bonds
of the solid iron and the covalent bonds
in the molecular oxygen
so anytime we are breaking and making
these chemical bonds
we have a chemical change now let me
give you an interesting question
what about the dissolving of sodium
chloride or table salt so you have
nacl in its solid form when you
place it into water you get sodium
chloride
in aqueous form and
how does that look when this happens
well sodium chloride in solid form
you know it forms this lattice
because they have these ionic bonds i'll
try to draw a few of them
so it looks something like this where
we've seen this multiple times chlorine
nabs electrons becomes chloride becomes
negative
sodium loses electron becomes a positive
ion and so they get attracted to each
other then they can form
this three-dimensional lattice structure
when it is
in solid form and i'm trying my best to
draw it in
three dimensions over here and actually
i could put
one right over here like this but when
you dissolve it into water
the ions get split apart you get the
ions that all get
dissolved to get split apart in the
water and so
the ionic bonds themselves are being
broken now you could argue that hey you
know the constituent ions are just being
separated so maybe this is a physical
change
or you could say no ionic bonds those
are legit bonds those are
strong bonds and those are getting
broken
and so you're also getting chemical
change it actually turns out that this
is a gray area when you're talking about
dissolving
a salt like this into water whether
you're talking about a physical change
or you're talking about a chemical
change and actually just this past
weekend i was at the beach
and we ran out of salt and i did it in
reverse
i went to the ocean and i got a pot full
of salt water
and it actually took me about 30 minutes
to boil it and i was able to evaporate
all of the water out of it
and essentially the salt in that water
was able to reform these ionic bonds
and so one could debate whether i was
creating a physical
or a chemical change i was definitely
doing a
physical change with the water i was
evaporating it
but i was actually forming ionic bonds
between the sodium and chloride so one
could argue that that was maybe a
physical and
a chemical change